dans ses cours de récréation de
vancouver des enfants juin écrit comme
ailleurs dans le monde mais quand ils
arrivent en classe ces petits de 6 7 ans
se prête à une séance plutôt inusité
pendant plusieurs minutes
encadrés par leurs enseignantes janice
il ferme les yeux et se concentrent sur
leur respiration durant leur journée à
l'école cet exercice de relaxation va se
répéter à trois reprises le matin en
rentrant en classe après le repas de
midi et à la fin des cours
c'est la base du programme mindup
appliquée dans les écoles primaires de
vancouver depuis 2005
j'ai remarqué que mes élèves n'ont pas
peur de prendre des risques quand ils
font des présentations de leurs travaux
par exemple qu'ils sont capables de
gérer leurs émotions pour participer en
classe
le programme comprend aussi des
exercices comme apprendre à déguster un
fruit ou prendre conscience de son corps
et maîtriser ses mouvements les élèves
prennent l'habitude de remercier
quotidiennement quelque chose ou
quelqu'un afin de souligner un événement
ou un sentiment positif respiration
relaxation gestion du stress et des
émotions en pâtit écoute et aide de
l'autre développement des pensées
positives
le tout afin de préparer son cerveau à
l'apprentissage
le programme diop a été fondée en 2003
aux états unis par l'actrice américaine
goldie hawn à partir d'études
scientifiques sur le développement du
cerveau et dans la foulée du traumatisme
des attentats du 11 septembre
depuis le programme a été implanté dans
les écoles de 28 états américains au
royaume uni à hong kong en australie en
chine et dans cinq villes de colombie
britannique
jennyfer ericsson a été une des
premières à appliquer le programme à
vancouver elle assure maintenant la
formation d'autres enseignants quand on
est blanc ce programme cela change tout
la culture de l'école l'établissement
devient un endroit plus attrayant pour
apprendre pour les élèves et donc cela
les aide à améliorer leur apprentissage
c'est ce que confirme une étude publiée
en janvier par cette chercheuse en
psychologie de l'université de colombie
britannique pendant quatre mois
elle a comparé deux groupes d'enfants de
10 11 ans 1 qui avait suivi le programme
mindup et l'autre sans ses enfants de 4e
et 5e années qui ont suivi le programme
cela améliorer leur bien-être leur
empathie le contrôle d'eux mêmes
cela aussi augmenté leurs résultats aux
examens de mathématiques et leur
capacité à maîtriser leur stress ainsi
15% des élèves ont eu de meilleurs
résultats en mathématiques car le
programme aiderait à la concentration
tout en réduisant le stress des atouts
dans l'apprentissage de cette matière
difficile
l'étude rapporte aussi que 58% des
enfants essayent d'aider leurs petits
camarades plus souvent que le programme
rend les enfants plus optimistes et
qu'il augmente la cohésion au sein de la
classe réduisant ainsi les comportements
agressifs
le programme made up est pratiqué par
plus de mille enseignants à vancouver
janis et jennifer disent que cela a
complètement changé leur façon de
travailler
je me concentre plus maintenant sur la
psychologie positive
l'aspect émotionnel et social de
l'apprentissage
comment notre cerveau fonctionne dans le
processus d'apprentissage et ça a été un
changement de vie pour être honnête
souvent les enfants ramènent les
techniques à la maison et des parents
témoignent de changement notable de
comportement c'est un outil merveilleux
même pour moi je vois déjà commencé à
une fille
alors je crois que ça va vraiment lui
permettre d'être consciente de ses
émotions et j'aime particulièrement le
fait que ce soit intégrée à
l'environnement de l'école je crois
qu'il faut dépasser ce débat à savoir
s'il est pertinent ou non de faire ces
enseignements dans les écoles la science
est claire il faut enseigner ces
principes dans les écoles maintenant ce
qu'il faut se demander c'est comment
poursuivre dans cette voie à cette
époque de rythme de vie effréné où le
stress contamine autant nourri que celle
de nos enfants
ces techniques de respiration de
relaxation et de pensées positives
inculquer aux tout petits sont des
outils intéressants qui pourraient même
leur servir leur vie durant
et si vous voulez poursuivre la
réflexion sur le sujet je vous invite à
consulter notre dossier web vous voyez
l'adresse à l'écran